consider two of which are related along
with the report on planning appeals I am
happy with this and intend to take the
business in the order but set out on the
agenda
item one apologies for absence
yes chair we haven't received apologies
from councilor R Hall and councilor Jay
Ridgeway thank you chair thank you
councilor Hancock is on his way
item two Declaration of Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests not already on their register
of interests
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare councilor Liggett
yeah I'm speaking on the first
application
um once I've spoken I'll believe in the
room okay thank you
item three minutes of the last meeting
we've now had the minutes of the meeting
held on the 22nd of November 2022.
those from the 13th of December will go
out on our next meeting
are we happy that they are a correct
record
thank you can I have show of hands
thank you
the minutes have been passed
moving on to the main minutes
the main business I should say sorry
before we start I would like the clerk
to explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on YouTube
how we will deal with them
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received
these updates have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to adjust the meeting
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
though we were a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to client and clarify any
points they have made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting but they will not be allowed
to participate further from that point
the chair will then open up the meeting
for questions to officers a debate by
the committee and finally determination
on the application by roads
the votes will be taken by roll call
family members this meeting is being
live streamed on YouTube and recording
is being made
this recording will be placed on the
council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you we'll move to the first
application which is Ned forward slash
twenty one four slash zero one three
seven six
over slash ol for sureland and I'll hand
over to our signing officer thank you
chair
um this is the application this
application is a suction sympathy
application to vary planning conditions
in order to provide a revised site
access for the extent extant outline
permission of 90 dwellings which was
allowed on appeal
the highway Authority have raised no no
objections
officers have sought independent legal
advice and of the view that the
relocation of the site access is not a
fundamental variation of the overall
permission for 90 dwellings that the
application can be determined as a
section 73 application
the proposals are constituted in
accordance okay sorry the proposals are
considered to be acceptable in terms of
their impact on the character of the
area and the adjacent Conservation Area
are set out in a report proposals would
have some impact on a TPO tree however
this is causally to be preferable to the
extant permission which would have a
greater impact on the TPO trees
the sliding
this shows the application side in the
center of the screen to the north it
backs onto existing housing on hallfield
Gate Lane to the South is sherland Golf
Course
to the West is hallfield Hall and
hallfield gate farm in the Conservation
Area
and the site lies adjacent to the shield
and settlement development limits and is
in the countryside
this is the red line application site
boundary Conservation Area is to the
West around hallfield gate farm
now this is a submitted illustrative
master plan so in the position of the
new access running along the western
boundary of 43 hawfield Gate Lane
this is a
this is that an extract of the
illustrative master plan submitted for
the extant scheme and the proposed
access this shows how the layout of the
houses might be located
this shows a location of the proposed
new access along with the visibility
splays and its position next to the
entry
these trees are subject to True
preservation order and whilst this tree
is to be obtained The Works are likely
to impact the tree however are set out
in the report this is considered to be a
better solution than the extant site
access
to the Eastern new footpath is proposed
to join up to the existing path on the
southern side of hallfield Gate Lane
this shows the approved site access
between two TPO trees this is the point
of the existing access to hawfield gate
farm and are set out in the report the
existing access has caused damage to the
two trees either side and the works to
form the approved access would cause
further damage to the trees
this is illustrative plan showing the
cross-sections of the internal Road this
plan in the following section show how
the access road might be achieved the
red line on the Eastern edge of the
access road is a proposed retaining wall
this shows the illustrative
cross-sections top one is 10 meters from
the site access bottom 30 meters these
are illustrative and the final details
will form part of the reserve matters
but
this is a photo taken for junction of
Byron Street and hawfield gate lane
looking towards the existing access
which is the approved access to the
development two trees either side are
the ones which will be impacted by the
creation of the approved site access
and this shows the position of the site
access and the affected tree part of the
access would run under the tree canopy
are set out in the report
this shows the front of number 43 where
the new footpath will join up with the
existing footpath roughly where the
burgundy had been decided on the left of
the photo a Hedgerow will be replaced
with a footpath than a 1.2 meter high
fans
foreign
way on the right opposed access and the
trees are on the left opposite the red
van and the approved access point can be
seen beyond the post and rail fence
to the left is a glass is the grass
Verge and Hedgerow number 43.
this slide is taken close to New access
looking towards the approved access and
shows the land slipping down towards the
access point
so thank you
thank you I believe we have several
speakers for this this first speaker is
the ward member councilor Charlotte
Cupid are you there Charlotte
yeah hi chair can everybody hate me yep
you've got three minutes off you go
perfect
um so I'm here today as one of the ward
members I wouldn't usually speak on a
technical variation application uh like
this but the problem for me is this
isn't a variation because of the
consequences it would have both for the
original application and crucially for
the surrounding residents and area
through what it's proposing
today's application is seeking to vary
the site access as has been outlined as
approved by the planning inspector when
this appeal was allowed and to move it
further down the lane the variation
essentially creates a dangerous
Crossroads at a place where there's a
bend in the road as you can see from
figure eight in your report
having read the report on all documents
in detail I don't believe the
consequences of this major change have
been fully analyzed or considered for
instance the traffic survey and travel
plan data submitted by the applicant
dates right back to 2017. as a further I
think telling example a search of the
travel assessment document for this
application to try to justify the
movements of the access doesn't even
mention once the Lilac Ray Junction it
would now be opposite and on page 27 of
the assessment the map is so out of date
it doesn't even include the 100 new
homes now opposite too
alongside concerns with the actual
proposals on the table here today at a
higher level proposing to moving access
for the not inconsiderable number of 90
dwellings to all but create a Crossroads
is a very different application to what
the inspector approved due to the
significant impacts the internal layout
of the site and the surrounding area as
well
moving the access would obviously mean
that developers would have to push back
houses up to where the road and access
previously was which would then be
closer to the conservation area and list
it all and more visible
is calm and shouldn't be determined for
me through this application or at a
later Reserve matters stage because if
commission is given for the movement of
the access it's automatically pretty
much allowing the houses to be moved
further up when we combine this with
some of the other things that would be
allowed under this variation such as a
proposingly retaining wall again a major
change and the removal of the hedgerows
and planting figure nine nine of your
report that previously screened the
development site and area I'm really
concerned that this proposal is
significantly munching away at the
landscape harm of this development which
the inspector in the original appeal
recognized and was Keen to mitigate
against
section seven of your committee report
does weigh this balance up and as with
any legal matter it's a judgment call
for each member of the committee today
on whether this really is a variation or
not and I hope some of the examples I've
touched on demonstrate that I don't
think it is
to this end I know there is some
residence objectives the seconds remain
application but even that doesn't convey
the strength of feeling of how concerned
residents are the problem is that
because this has been submitted as a
variation it's become a technical
process when as I've outlined I can't
reach the conclusion that it is because
it goes back to the core principles of
this development residents should get
the chance to have more of a say on what
is a major change and will have a
significant impact so I urge the
committee to refuse this variation thank
you chair
thank you are there any questions
no
thank you Charlotte our next speaker is
councilor Heather Liggett Another War
member
three minutes when you're ready
thank you the new entrance I believe
does affect the whole application surely
the entrance to a site is part of the
overall application the new entrance is
too close to the entrance of lilac way
which is now also the entrance to the
new Fox holidays development which is an
extra 40 houses so approximately 80 more
cars using the exit onto hallfield Gate
Lane
residents have come to me already
because of the bad visibility pulling
out of violet way onto whole field Gate
Lane the proposed new entrance is at a
part of the site which is much lower
than the road approximately 15 feet
lower this will require a retaining wall
which may even be gabians how will that
look from the conservation area of
hallfield gate
the developer claims the new entrance
will only damage one tree instead of the
two trees at their first entrance
apparently these two trees may already
have suffered damage so now we could be
talking about three TPO trees being
damaged plus the removal of a mixed
hedge 7.7 in your packs for a pavement
that goes nowhere as the South pavement
on hallfield gate lane ends before Lane
house several hundred yards short of the
a61 so everyone will have to cross to
the north pavement to safely to safely
reach the a61 for buses and the primary
school
we already have a problem with whole
field Gate Lane the north side of
hallfield Gate Lane has two rows of
terraced houses so no off-road parking
which means all day every day a solid
line of parked cars this is meant for
months a few residents
on the pavement as a preventative method
of stopping cars mounting the pavement
and running the whole length of the lane
on the pavement
there have been dozens of accidents on
the Broward the hill also a child was
knocked down having stepped off the
school bus due to the Mayhem of parked
cars are stated by a residence resident
this is a rural Lane used by very large
tractors and trailers all year round
the photos that you've been shown
committee show show the lane the west
side of the lane not where all the
housing and issues are
thank you
thank you are there any questions
thank you councilor
our next speaker is a Mr Richard
southley it's an objector
if you'd like to state your name and you
understand you've got three minutes
what's this do I yes hello good
afternoon
I'd like to say the time of the same
opinion as the other 20 odd people who
have submitted objections to this latest
proposed development site entrance
change
as it is in an even more dangerous
location than the original
being closer to the junction at lilac
way with further visibility issues and
at the narrowest point of the lane
I'd also like to mention that the
original application was rejected at all
local levels only succeeding upon
National appeal
objections to this development are well
documented and the proposed new access
and the resultant changes to the built
layout are not sufficiently minor enough
to Warrant consideration under the
section
as these amount are amendments which
should form part of a new application
furthermore in addition to addition to
this seven Trend have submitted their
concerns and comments regarding drainage
plans for the above and disposable of
both surface water and foul sewage they
also say they may need to undertake a
more comprehensive study of the
catchment to determine if Capital
Improvements are required the reason for
this is to ensure the development is
provided with a satisfactory means of
drainage as well as to reduce the risk
of creating or exacerbating flooding and
pollution
to my knowledge no undertaking of the
above has been submitted by the
applicants and again this should be
obtained before any permission to go
ahead is granted I'm particularly and
personally disturbed by this as I live
at the old gas Cottage down pit Lane
which lies south of the proposed
development and in my original letter
Express concern at the lack of any plans
by jda regarding the issue of surface
water storage or flooding as in their
technical considerations heading in
section four they falsely claimed that
the site does not fall within an area at
being at risk from flooding and went on
to say that the flood risk is low and
that it would not displace flood water
in the one in 100 Year event and
therefore no flood water storage or
mitigation measures were required or
proposed
in recent property in recent years our
property has flooded twice and our
garden
we have invested a lot of time and money
digging deeper and wider culverts
creating a larger stream but year on
year we need to dig the stream deeper
and wider with the more developments
that are generated and granted we are
left to our own devices to get rid of
the surface water sometimes mixed with
foul sewerage which leaves us with many
undesirable items including toilet
tissue sanitary plugs condoms and the
like I ask you to please reject this
application for the reasons I've set out
that's time thank you thank you are
there any questions and speaker
now if you'd like to take your seat
thank you
our next speaker is the Mr Kevin bush
hello good afternoon
so I'm Kevin bush
three minutes when you're ready thank
you
so my my main points are
um the proposed recycling of the access
will move it to what must be the most
dangerous point on the Frontage of the
site the traffic assessment submitted is
out of date to the point of being
useless as there have been hundreds of
new homes built not only insurance but
the surrounding areas as well all of
which have significantly increased
traffic pressure on the lane
the proposal to move the axis has
majorly altered the boundary of the
original approval and has a substantial
effect on the site housing and Road plan
layouts
proposed housing has been squeezed to
the east of the site to achieve the
proposed changes
the work required to create the post
access is not trivial retention rules
and in banking will be required which
will be ugly and Industrial in
appearance and totally out of keeping
with the surrounding area
I believe the substantial nature of
these factors as well as the fact that a
new section 106 agreement will need to
be approved dictate that the proposed
changes are not minor variations and
should not be considered as section 73a
changes thank you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you very much okay and our
final speaker Mr Paul Webster
three minutes when you're ready Mr
Webster
uh sorry could you use your mic thanks
hello can you hear me yep
um yeah sorry this will be short and
sweet a lot of the information to
support this uh change of uh access has
already been mentioned
um I'm just here really as a fellow
neighbor supporting the uh the decision
um to move this access which is uh
totally out of totally out of order the
uh the the houses that are being put in
place and again just revisiting what the
other people have said in the access
um and the the danger to the road
um I just believe that you know as a
traffic goes more sort of East on
Orville Gate Lane and it becomes quite
very very dangerous uh especially for
the additional parking that I've noticed
recently where people are parking on the
lane to access the school for dropping
children off and things you know it's
creating a lot of unnecessary
um I believe that at home new
application these points in place as
it's a total change
um and again I've spoken to people about
the uh the uh water that is uh obviously
collected in on the field uh where the
where the planning is going to be okay
thank you
thank you are there any questions if
you'd like to take your seats fine thank
you
are there any questions for the planning
officers
my goodness
answer earlier than cancer Amity
thank you
Adrian or fella I don't know who's
Belinda Anthony what is the actual
reason behind moving the the site
entrance
what's the actual reason they've not
provided an actual reason uh that's what
worries me
but absolutely agents or the upgrade
here to be able to to answer that or
they've submitted the application and
obviously they need to determine it
but the actual why they don't want to
implement the egg stamp rather than this
then they haven't provided that now
Council Armitage thank you chat uh how
many uh of the trees uh with JPL was on
are you uh are proposed to be uh
destroyed
none are proposed to be removed but this
is too
there's two where the existing access is
which have been impacted by the
um works that kind of had it already and
what the further impacted by the
implementation of the approved scheme
the proposed access would impact
wandering
and you consider that
okay if it impacts the tree that's been
there all these years and certainly the
purpose as ever uh when we're encouraged
all the way around the country to be
planting trees and the impact of this is
going to cause this tree probably to to
die because it would be damaged to the
root protection area
it's a case of we either allow two trees
to be damaged
or wanted to be damaged so this is seen
as the the lesser of two evils a guy
surely it will be better not to damage
any of the trees
are there any further questions
sorry about this coming back to you when
you when you gave your presentation you
said there was likely to be some impacts
on the trees uh if I'm a new
Ingress egress was was given permission
what what is the impact on those trees
do you mean they're actually coming down
or they could be damaged or
I mean it sets out in in paragraph
um 7.39 of the report our tree officer's
view is that the widening of the access
as approved by the inspector will cause
significant damage to both of the trees
either side of that access the tree
offers advisors that the newly proposed
access to the east of the TPO trees is a
better option as well as the new access
appears to show it cutting through the
root protection area of one of the
protected trees this will have a lesser
impact overall on the TPO trees so
that's why I would come to the
conclusion that we've come to
yeah just just on that point to add to
what what Phil's said is as officers we
tried to be transparent about that and
accept that there will be an impact on
the one tree as Phil said but the advice
we've got from the tree officer is that
impact
is the lesser of the two outcomes and
affecting the two trees that lie outside
the the radius of the approved scheme so
if you were to refuse consent this
afternoon the applicant could still go
ahead with the x-stamp permission with
the impact on the two trees
if you were to Grant consent this
afternoon that would have the impact on
the one tree and so that is the balance
that we as officers have come forward
with in our recommendation we believe
that impact is the lesser of those two
situations that we prefer not to be
faced with but we are faced with one
that can go ahead
we believe that the the one tree being
impact is the less of those two evils in
effect and that's the balance that we've
concluded on so quite quite a simple
planning judgment from it from an office
point of view and members will need to
take a view whether you agree with that
notwithstanding the other matters that
you might throw into the mix but that's
the issue on the arboricultural issue
that we've we've concluded
I've got a list here
um
councilor Cooper followed by councilor
Hancock followed by a councilor Armitage
Homeland councilor
thank you chair
um still I
think of early flight
it said that possibly two trees
in the permission that's already been
granted could already have been damaged
so in effect
we could be damaging three trees
it's the extent to what I want to know
about the first two trees it's the
extent to damage what's been caused
already and will that have an impact
further down the line
Council Hancock
thank you chair
um I'm just intrigued as to why officers
feel that this is a minor Amendment
because obviously it's quite significant
and the arboricultural aspect is just
one aspect but that in itself doesn't
really explain why overall you feel that
it's a minor Amendment but it seems to
be a pretty major one
we've set out that quite comprehensively
in the report we've sort of we've sought
independent legal advice from Barrister
on uh whether it can be dealt with at a
section 73 the description of the of the
application isn't changing it's now an
application for 90 dwellings so from a
single point of access so what they're
doing is they're relocating access one
point to another so it's still going to
be nice to dwell in certain from a
single point of access on the whole bill
Gateway so in that respect we consider
that it's um it can be used as a sexual
sympathy application to vary the
conditions
just to to add to uh to what Phil's been
said the the issue of whether it's minor
or not that doesn't actually appear in
the legislation there's no definition of
what is minor or not the section 73
merely allows an application to be made
to implement a permission without
compliance with the original imposed
conditions you can then impose other
conditions to replace them if you like
but the issue about minor and we as
officers use that phrase as well but
minor is not a word that appears in
section 73 itself it's just an
application to implement development
without compliance with a recently
imposed conditions so my advice to
members will be to to try not to get too
wedded to the issue of whether it's
minor or not in effect you're being
asked to Grant an alternative permission
to the one that's been granted on appeal
and you need to consider that in terms
of the the changes that are proposed in
this instance they are related as Phil's
just said to the to the access point
because all the other matters will be
dealt with at any reserve matters
application so if you were to Grant
permission this afternoon the applicant
would have two options
could implement the original or any new
permission you grant if you were to
refuse it they would just be able to
implement as it stands the originally
approved scheme yeah thanks Adrian
because I've I've had that argument
before with with officers in terms of in
terms of that
um and with respect to Phil it's not
really that comprehensive because yeah
all they're doing is they're tweaking
stuff to make sure they fit within the
same description it's not really saying
why you feel that moving the road is not
a huge issue moving the access point is
not a huge issue
um so that's what I'm trying to get to
because obviously that's that's really
one of the key things isn't it in in
terms of this with its new location
more than it being a hold of an
application
and
I come back to the to the report though
eight nine paragraphs in the report on
the on the legal opinion it's not
changing the operative part of the
commission it's 90 dwelling served up a
single access
so
um it can be dealt with as a variation
of the condition
councilor Armitage thing councilor Jones
and councilor Elliot
thank you Jack
so all these trees all have gpos I'm
arrived
that's the two trees
right if you damage if if a tree dies
off
uh you're likely to be fined uh because
you've not uh
chat with the uh
uh route protection area uh and no doubt
that to the uh developer I'm going to
take this into consideration
and it's like my learner friend on the
left here said you're going to end up
or could end up with three dead GPO
trees and my argument is what's the
point of in the TPO if you're going to
allow them to be damaged and die off
the second point is
I am I right in assuming well this
traffic survey was done in 2017.
our topic surveys dated
um
could you use your mic please
traffic surveys dated November 20 the
traffic assessment date of November 21
but the information within it the
appendices do yes they do date back to
to 2016 however
the how we implications of development
are still going to be 90 dwellings onto
hawfield Gate Lane
and the highway Authority haven't raised
an issue on the transport assessment and
they have had no objection to the
proposals so yes while some of the
information within that transport survey
is dated that is still going to be the
90 dwellings going on hawthorn gate lane
from the approved scheme
but am I right to assume that since that
2017 uh information was given there's
been a close on another hundred houses
uh developed nearby which haven't been
which weren't dated into consideration
at this point and we can't really uh
accept the accuracy of this surely
if it was a new application I would
agree with you but it's it's we're
talking about an extant position for 90
dwellings is already 90 dwellings going
on to that that
it was that proved in two years ago
I think that's that's the important
point in in this as well Chan that there
is an extant permission granted on
appeal that can be subject to approval
of Reserve matters can be implemented
without the submission of any additional
Highway data any additional highway
information permission was granted on
appeal for that access position as part
of that approved scheme so that is a an
x-stamp permission that's subject to
approval of those those matters can be
implemented without any additional
information and as Phil said in in this
instance the highway Authority have not
raised any objection so your your
statutory advisors have not raised any
objections from a high waist point of
view to this revised access and again
that as officers chair that's what we've
placed and placed a weight on in in
supporting the views of those those
experts
thank you councilor Jones
yeah I was going to just support what
councilor Cooper said about the you know
the impact on the Three Trees two have
already been impacted am I right about
that because the things that started
and we can't
you know if the other development of the
other access is happening
how are they going to get Machinery to
that are they going to go through the
one that's already there and around the
back I think we could end up like um
Council Armitage science with the three
trees be damaged
yes
um well like I said the works that have
already been have been done I
have created a problem and
um if they Implement their approved
scheme then there will be further damage
to those trees according to our tree
officer
councilor Elliott
thanks Chet um I'm moving away from
trees I'm back to I'm still not
particularly Satisfied by the answer
given about why they want to move the
access that's the portion I'm not
satisfied with I know you don't have to
ask and I know there's like stunt uh and
I know the highways thing I read on 4.3
gallons around which is that it says it
was last looked at in 2021 and 2017 but
my my favorite is with the high waist
thing they may have looked at it then
but did they take into consideration the
new development and and the amount of
houses that were being built close by
and the movements of vehicles and the
flip side to all that is uh were they
given the latest plans not working off
old Maps the latest plans showing that
development it may have come to a
different conclusion or am I wrong with
that because I don't know
they've got no objections that they've
been consulted on the information that
that we've got
um some of you wouldn't know about the
latest ones showing the new developments
I presume that they've got the same
plans that we have in terms of the
Ordinance survey which which we'll show
it here
Lisa did you want to speak
I was actually struggling to
um hear what um Council was saying no no
it's fine I think it chair if I may I
think what members have got in front of
them is
um a legal opinion about the mechanism
of how this application has been brought
about
um you have evidence before you from the
professionals the experts I suppose in
in terms of the um highways Authority
and we can't go behind or look behind
what information there may not may or
may not have taken into consideration
and you've also got the advice from the
um Tree Specialist or professional who's
who's provided some advice with regards
to the impact on the trees in question I
think it's about bringing all that
information together for the members
when they they come to debate and and
make their decision really
thank you chair
thank you
are there any other questions counselor
uh yeah I just wanted to ask um is there
anything
um you know with regard to the um extent
entrance uh what will happen to that
entrance once if we were to Grant
permission for this one
the if permission was grants for this as
Aiden said earlier they would have in
effect two position two permissions so
they could either implement the original
one or they could implement this section
Cemetery he couldn't do both so access
if they implemented the approved
permission would stay as it is
we're just serving orfield gate farm
the questions
no I'm going to ask the clerk now to go
through the motions before we put that
through
yes thank you chair
um please bear in mind members an
emotion must be moved and seconded
before the vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that Amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving the motion
against officer recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls
or in other words this is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further Motion in
favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the times and the Motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached and then we'll invite
members to put motions forward
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to propose a motion
before them thank you chair
thank you I shall open the floor for
debate Council Foster
thank you chair
um I've got no objection in principle to
this uh development it's gone to a
rigorous process it's already gone
through the planning inspector and it's
come back as something which is
um you know which has got Merit and he's
been given permission so no objection in
principle but when you look at all the
things that have been mentioned here and
uh
I'd consider many of these major changes
we got the creation of a Crossroads
which is in a reportedly dangerous
position reportedly we've got all
traffic information dated back to 2017
and it is from 2017. uh it doesn't cover
the new recent 100 ohms uh very nearby
on the other side of the road it doesn't
cover uh the plan developments at Park
Lane
uh and as for we've heard uh highway
it's been mentioned a few times quite a
few times I mentioned by officers that
uh they've not opposed it well highway
is done in my opinion and they're
thinking many people's opinion oppose
many things at all so choose more words
carefully on that so for me when it
comes to highways not objecting uh that
shouldn't be seen as for me a green
light that should be seen as they're
just not objected as they've not said
anything we've had no response that's
how I see uh highways now that's that's
as much much weight up on that
department
uh the returning walls which have been
mentioned several times uh and I said to
be able to keep him with the
surroundings
the removal of a large extended hedge
the three touching trees and I I take
the point that it's one tree and two
trees that take that point the concerns
around visibility for road safety and
also we've heard that there may need to
be a new section 106 agreement now all
of those things put together that's
quite a long list and I think there were
a few more points there
uh we're asking we're asked here to
consider this as a variation the section
73. now page 21 7.8 a section 73
application is an application for
planning permission for the development
of land without complying with
conditions
subject which a previous permission was
granted
so it's it's about taking those
conditions away now if you think it's
been through that process already it's
been through the process where it came
locally and it's been to a planning
inspect the planning inspector has put
those conditions on for a reason it was
looked at thoroughly the first time and
proper regard was given to this
uh detailed regarding not just here not
just through our our process with the
officers not just through this planning
committee that turned it down but also
in depth and it's an appeal so this uh
the builders are wanting to do away with
those actual conditions now those
conditions are being looked at in too
much detail for us here just to grant
that variation
uh and I think it thoroughly warrants
that this is a full new application
again because of those reasons and it's
only fair we can see the level of uh
objections we've got and the level of
Interest we've got from Ward members
from residents
it is that there's an awful lot of uh
concern around this application and we
won't do it justice here to let this
variation go through absolutely not it's
not that I'm against this development it
needs looking at properly and we're only
being responsible I Believe by letting
this be a full new application uh so
that's my future thank you
any other comment manual can Justin
cancer now if I can just come back again
when uh appropriate please councilor
Armitage
I agree with the council Foster said all
the way through you know it's there's
still many different uh things that have
gone on here and we need to look at them
the other thing is
at other uh plenty committees we
actually have somebody from that I've
seen other people other authorities have
somebody from highways Now isn't it time
that we have uh somebody from the
highway department who can speak and
explain himself rather than just getting
a a blurb from them saying it no
problems
as we mentioned highways that it's
happening from January with someone
coming to talk to us
just um on the points to be a major if I
may first of all the point that cancer
Armitage is made regarding Highway
advice as you've just mentioned there is
um a representative from the highway
Authority coming to give you some um
discuss with you Highway issues and
their comments and prior to planning
committee in January I understand but um
up to this point whilst we have asked on
a number of occasions for Highway
colleagues to come to finally committee
their advices but no you have our advice
and we're not able to to service every
planning Authority in derbyshire's
planning meetings but that may change in
the future in terms of the the issues
that have been raised chair in effect
members are being asked to consider
whether the scheme that was approved in
outline the access approved on appeal is
acceptable in its revised form so you're
being asked whether the scheme in its
whole can be implemented but with the
three conditions are set out in the
report altered so you are at Liberty to
now consider whether this revision
in its form is acceptable so you can
take into account
issues of whether the new access is in
the correct Place issues of Highway
Safety impact on the trees you're very
welcome to to take into account those
issues because they impact directly on
what would be a revised scheme so you
can take those into account now and you
don't need another application
necessarily to do that if you don't
believe that the application before you
this afternoon is acceptable for those
reasons that you've discussed and you're
at liberty and quite within your rights
to refuse it for those reasons and then
the applicant either has to revert back
to the permission granted or seek and
redress on appeal potentially so you do
have that opportunity now and those
issues are all material to this issue so
as officers have said and the report our
view on them is clear and we believe
that on the balance the revised scheme
would be acceptable that's the decision
you need to take this afternoon however
as I often to committee
you've talked this afternoon and you've
heard about issues of Highway Safety
danger and new position being dangerous
in terms of creating a Crossroads
all we have in terms of the evidence is
the information put before us and the
advice that we receive from the highway
Authority on that so again I would
caution you on placing weight on
comment hearsay without evidence and
this afternoon I've not heard any
technical evidence why all those
elements would amount to the being an
impact on an adverse impact on highway
safety so again Chad I just asked
members to to caution the weight that
you're placing on comment made and you
need to be sure if you're minded to
refuse the application on issues of
Highway Safety that you're happy that
you have evidence to support that if
tested on appeal hopefully that's
helpful chair thank you
thank you are there any further comments
right I'll ask for someone to put board
in motion
councilor Foster yeah I'm happy to
propose that uh this revision is not
acceptable and that they share the
applicant should rely on the extent
permission which they already got
you've beaten cancer Elliot's got there
before you William
we're looking for reasons chair it's all
the reasons are stated initially uh
which is that these are major changes
the constant major changes and you can
cite all the ones uh I'm sure they're
recorded uh but going back that the
traffic information is old and does not
take into account all the recent uh
buildings
uh recent applications the new homes uh
the retaining walls at the removal of a
large extended hedge the threatened
trees and the concerns around visibility
for road safety so if we include all of
those
um
yeah the potential Crossroads
thank you chair
happy with that if if I'm age here um
listening to the debate and the comments
of councilor Foster it does seem to me
as though there may be two different
elements to the concerns of members the
first relates to highway safety and
how's the Fosters talk share about the
date of the original information
the visibility that's been mentioned
visibility display I presume the
proposed access the creation of the
crossroads
and I think they were the the um
the main elements of that and then they
seemed to me to be uh impact on Carriage
of the area in terms of trees retaining
wall
and the removal of the Hedge so my view
chair is that um the debate I've heard
is is that members would be voting on
two two issues one around highway safety
one around impact on the character there
and that would be members online into
refuse it that's that would be an
appropriate way of going
everyone okay with that so just to be
clear Adventure it's to refuse the
application contrary to officer
recommendations on the grounds well two
grounds which have just been discussed
there because of that uh well first of
all because it's not
um a simple
um so how can a product revision it's
actually more than that and in
particular two areas in which it's more
than that around highway safety and in
particular this information this
question about whether the information
uh used by how those was up to date uh
the visibility of access and the
creation of a Crossroads as one stream
and then the second one would be on the
impact on the character of the area
um particular and the the three
mentioned trees uh the retaining wall
and hedgerows is that the essence of it
members
that's fine sure thank you
we'll now move to the boat
we're just going to be by role
because I like doing it like that
thank you chair
counselor Armitage
counselor Cooper
councilor Elliot
councilor Foster for
councilor Hancock for
that's the hearts on or
councilor Jones
or
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse
councilor Roth oh
that's unanimous chair the Motions
passed thank you all very much
you could just wait one more mature
while we get counselor they get back in
do you need to change Taxi
we're on his way
thank you very much thank you
thank you
if you guys came
foreign
it's not working
here
Mr Bush can you uh now just close your
account
hello Martin I think um Mr Bush's
account um has been rained open can
would you be able to remove him please
yes would you be able to
um remove the uh Kevin's account uh from
the room please
okay round two
our next application is for sureland
oh no it's not it's straight and I beg
your pardon which is ned4 slash 22
400884 forward slash RM this is being
taken by Graham Cooper just before
Graham comes in chair just to update
members in respect to the late
representation that were sent to all
members of planning committee this
morning at 10 o'clock via the email so
I'm presuming that all members have seen
and and been able to read that so I
won't go into a detail chair but just
for the record just to state that we had
them a commenting from Mr Harry's at 10
o'clock this morning which was copied
into all members I went with any details
chairman of courses as we go on if there
are any queries and questions happy to
accept them
thank you over YouTube Graham
okay thank you chair we'll just wait for
the
um
I'll just wait for the presentation to
come in front of us so our chair members
they'll be all right so this is item two
and it's the first of two applications
members will be considering today that
land east of prospect House istas Lane
Stratton
this is a section 73 application to vary
condition one approved plans
very previously approved layout and
Landscaping details
a number of late representations have
been received which have been reported
to members in the late representations
pack and verbally today by Adrian
it's worth noting that the previous
commission 28 dwellings remains extinct
and work is commencing on site
the main issue here being whether or not
the changes to the layout and
Landscaping details are acceptable on
the site
and the impact on the surrounding area
impact on residents privacy and Immunity
and the impact on the trees to the West
at the site
so this slide that's before you here is
illustrates the site shaded in Orange
the a61 there lies to the East High
stairs Lane
to the South
a band of trees some of which are
protected by TPL are located at the
western boundary of the site
prospects house lies Beyond this these
this band of trees to the West you can
probably just make it out there on the
left
this property is approximately
35 to 40 meters away from this boundary
there's a few properties to the south on
Heist as Lane
so that's the location plan there in
front of members and so that's the
application site in red and other land
under the applicants control in blue
next slide it
so this slide illustrates the proposed
layout for 28 dwellings and also shows
the previously approved route protection
area shaded red around the trees to the
west of the site are refer to as the RPA
moving forward
for the next slide please
so this slide offers a visual comparison
between previously
so this if you can make out you've got
a comparison of
so this is a yeah if we move forward one
slide so this no that's fine thank you
so this slide so apologies about that so
it's just more zoomed in
version of the site plan and compares
the previously approved RPA Illustrated
with a dashed line it also illustrates a
new proposed protective fence line with
a DOT dashed line hopefully you can make
that out
this proposed protective fence line is
further away than the previously
approved RPA and is in the most part
further away from the agreed RPA
an agreement with the tree officer and
the council and the applicant conditions
to remove permitted development rights
to works of properties along the western
boundary of the application site and a
scheme of soil amelioration are
recommended
so this slide illustrates the proposed
Landscaping scheme which differs
slightly from that previously approved
and then it includes additional burden
bat boxes
on the properties on the Northern edge
of the site and replaces a laurel hedge
with a more native species planting Edge
thanks like this
so members who attended the virtual site
visit yesterday will have seen a
comprehensive Suite of site photos these
next few slides offer a reminder of the
key features
this photo being taken from the site
entrance
and you see the trees along the western
boundary of the site in the background
there
so this photo is just taken a bit
further up high stairs Lane across View
West towards the western boundary of the
site you can see the protective fencing
that's been installed on site
and the final photo
this is taken from the grounds of
prospect house
and looks East towards the proposed
development
and that concludes the presentation
thank you
thank you
and we'll move on to our first Speaker
once I've found my list which is I
believe Lucy Harris
Mrs Harris before you start I understand
your husband can't be here this
afternoon so I'm going to allow you five
minutes instead of the normal three
so when you're ready
it's essential that the impact of
significant changes to the development
as proposed today are given a full and
fair consideration I note that the
developer breached a number of planning
conditions already in place to protect
the trees under a TPO within the first
few weeks that they started work I know
because I stopped the diggers myself so
exist the existing approved scheme use
the council funded jumbo tree report
following issues with the tree
information submitted by the previous
applicant we had argue strongly that the
measurements used in this approval were
wrong but this committee approved the
development using the methodology and
data contained within the John Booth
report
on receiving details of this application
we requested that the current tree
officer David Cunningham visit the site
and look at our concerns particularly
given the proposed changes on scale and
layout so David and Graham Cooper
attended our
site and took measurements and finally
proved that there were inaccurate
measurements and agreed that these
needed to be corrected so great finally
somebody was listening somebody
listening there's a new application and
there's a real opportunity to put this
right so when the correct measurements
are put into the approved John Booth
methodology they show that in fact there
are buildings within the route
protection area so this is an
opportunity these buildings could be
moved at this stage this could be
corrected and the trees could be given
proper protection
we waited for feedback after the visit
and we waited and we waited we received
no response from the tree officer for or
for Mr Cooper
then this meeting got booked the officer
sends out his report stating there's
been a change to the methodology from
that that was used by John Booth he'd
group the trees together to use the
largest tree to determine the maximum
extent of the roots and when the correct
measurements are used these give maximum
protection to the roots the method for
determining the RPA in today's
application referencing the office in
the officer's report is one approved and
undocumented method I mean what else can
I say when today there is no tree report
from that visit and the updated
measurements so if this is so critical
why has it not been shared we've
contacted officers repeatedly we've
asked for today's meeting to be deferred
to allow that information to be put
together fairly and comprehensively in
the same way that the John Booth report
was
I mean has the true report even been
written off the back of that visit who
knows you can see for yourselves in
figure three on the planning officers
report that the changes in this
application have led to the buildings
been removed in relation to the RPA
sadly today I'm not allowed to show you
drawings where if you take the approved
methodology and the correct measurements
it does show that with the revised
scheme there is encroachment into the
RPA in plots six and seven
now obviously it's not just me saying
that the application must remain in line
with the John Booth report this was laid
down in the approval documentation of
this scheme in 2018 and 2019 it was
actually labeled on one of the site
plans that were shown a few minutes ago
both document States as I'm sure you'd
be familiar with that the development
shall hereby be carried out in
accordance with this clan unless
otherwise subsequently agreed through
formal submission under Amendment
procedures there has been no submission
to approve an alternative methodology in
this application in fact there's been no
alternative tree survey submitted to
determine any changes from the John
Bruce report all we have are a few
comments in the officer's report I note
the tree officer made further comments
that were uploaded to the portal at 3
P.M yesterday this was following the
tree officer advising Oz just a few
hours earlier that he wasn't able to
respond to our questions ahead of
today's meeting
but to be honest I brushed email clearly
made in response to our late comments
doesn't change the approved plans and
the requirements for the RPA I would
rather think that it's somebody trying
to cover themselves for what is a pretty
embarrassing situation this application
must be rejected today as when the
approved methodology is used with the
correct measurements the RPA is
encroached it's that simple and at the
end of the day all we are asking for is
transparency fairness and protecting the
trees
thank you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you if you'd like to take a
seat
I believe we have another speaker a John
Milhouse the agent
I have three minutes when you're ready
okay five minutes sorry
thank you everybody my name is John
Milhouse I'm a chartered Town planner
and I'm here today representing the
applicants Meadowview homes
I'd like to thank officers for a
thorough report and for their
recommendation for approval
the previous owners of this site Wild
Goose Holmes obtained all the necessary
consents and made a technical start the
development
before going into Administration my
clients many of you homes purchased the
site earlier this year with the next
stamp planning permission
meaning that they are entitled to
complete the approved development and
indeed works are well underway on the
roadways and the groundworks
but as is normal in the development
industry they want to build their own
house types hence these applications
now this first application considers
layout and Landscaping so I'll touch on
those two points
in terms of layout the layout is very
similar to the approved layout
the access is in the same place all the
roads are in exactly the same place and
the houses are in a very similar
position
that said it is not necessary for the
layout to be identical for this scheme
to be acceptable the question is whether
the changes are acceptable in planning
terms
there's only been one objection to this
scheme and it suggested that the size
and scale the proposal has increased
significantly
and I understand that is the reason why
this application is before committee
this afternoon
I strongly disagree with this
interpretation
the overlay plan which was on the screen
earlier
clearly shows that the layout layout is
extremely similar
some of the plots are slightly larger
others are slightly smaller and some
garages have become integral but the
overall footprint of buildings has
increased by less than 0.3 percent
the plot closest to the objector plot
seven
has increased by 1.5 meters but its
width has reduced by 0.9 meters the
Eve's height has been reduced by 0.4
meters and the ridge height has been
reduced by 0.8 meters and my
measurements actually
um show that the the plot is 56 meters
from the uh the neighboring house behind
a substantial tree line
regarding the trees although the
applicants are entitled to build the
previously approved scheme which means
the previously approved tree protection
fence line
my clients have independently
commissioned their own new tree survey
this has been independently verified by
your own tree officer and if I could
just quote your tree officer from the
office's report he says the protective
fencing plan looks ideal and appears to
demonstrate we can both successfully
support the proposal and protect the
nominal rpas of retained trees so we're
not relying on Old reports that have
been questioned we've had a new tree
survey and what's really important here
is the new tree line that's being
offered even though the applicants can
build to the old one is further away
from the trees so if this application is
approved the trees will be better
protected than the existing permission
the improved fence line has already been
installed on site to the satisfaction of
your enforcement officer at a site
meeting
and at the request of the planning
officer the the applicants have agreed
to plant a native hedge throw along the
road front and install uh baton bird
boxes
so in conclusion Meadowview homes are
derbyshire-based house Builder who
bought the site and employ local people
they recently completed a similar
development in this District at
Westington to a high standard
they bought a site that's had a planning
permission for housing since 2014 so
it's been included in the council's
housing delivery numbers
they brought in good faith they want to
finish the development
in doing so they'll help Meet The
District's housing needs they'll honor
all the affordable housing contributions
that have been set out in the 106
agreement
the scheme has been thoroughly
scrutinized by your offices it's it's
obtained the support of the case officer
the tree officer and the enforcement
officer on site
all we ask for is that the applicants
are allowed to continue to build without
any further or necessary costly delay
thank you
thank you are there any questions
I have one quite simple one plot seven
could you bring up Graham the the layout
of the site if possible
just bear with me a second chair please
I'm sure it's possible it's just
whether I'm working with everything
foreign
that's it so that's quite a distance
isn't it from the nearest one Prospect
house its nearest neighbor
Prospect house chair is
and the one that's outlined in green at
the South Western course that's Prospect
house here okay thank you thank you
there are planning planting in front of
that aren't you so that's kind of the
Gap that's there will be filled in
anyway over time yes thank you very much
would you like to take a seat
yeah just to to be clear the photographs
that Graham went through earlier showed
planting on the prospect house side of
the boundary rather than within the
application site
are there any questions for the officers
councilor Elliot
thank you
great and when you when you gave your
presentation he said the fencing that
had been put up to protect the tree
roots was in part
saying what did you mean by impart same
it is some closer to prospect house
boundary further away because I'm I'm
now getting two different ideas of where
it is you know the speakers have said
it's closer but the agent is saying it's
actually further away and protecting
them even more also can you comment on
the Hedgerow because I know when this
application went through back in
whenever it was I was on that committee
as well and they were moving the ancient
edgeros and putting them back on our
stairs Lane but there's no mention of
anything being planted by the contractor
along the development side of prospect
house am I led to believe that you're
saying the photo shows Prospect house
and Edge rolls that were there and it's
up to them to to screen it with a rose
Day plant
so yeah there's a few points
that's gonna be quite tedious
so hopefully this
that is the previously approved route
protection area which we approved
uh so I'm afraid that we've got a
technical problem in Hamas and so we'll
just press ahead
I'm quite happy for the answer question
to be answered
I know that we've got there is some form
of hedge line there but not a great deal
yeah
foreign
there when you look at the layout there
was looked as if there was a gap
and that photograph chair is the one
that you referred to earlier this is
taken from within the garden of prospect
house
any other questions
Council Armitage
uh it's been mentioned about the
discrepancies in the actual measurements
uh of one thing or another uh by one of
the speakers uh and I wonder if you
could clarify it as to which methodology
you use and how accurate it is
okay
okay hopefully that you can hear from
that so the I believe you know and I'm
not a tree expert uh
that Mr Booth took the view that he
grouped
a collection of trees together to create
a to create the to measure the distance
rather than doing it individually so
when David and I the tree officer went
to site
he suggested that was not the way that
he would do things and he would
individually measure from those trees so
we took measurements from all those
trees with Mr and Mrs Harry's and we
came up with the root protection area
so what happened after that point is we
put those measurements to the developer
the measurements that we collated on
site
they produced a clean plan which showed
the new root protection area
the tree officer reviewed that plan and
found that it was it was in line with
what he would expect
hopefully that clarifies that much
thank you councilor Cooper
just staying on that thanks chair just
staying on that point and obviously
we've heard from
one of the speakers talking about the
lack of information on the planning
portal with regards the the tree report
or the lack of a tree report can we just
because for me as a as a member I don't
know which of those
which of those methods is the right
method
um we've gone from one method to another
method
which can obviously
um give a little bit of a
misunderstanding I guess to members for
me I'd like to see
whichever whichever planning application
it is we're going to use a method that's
consistent
um so so really I'd like to know why the
information has been put on there so
late for people to be able to see that
just on that point chat the issue around
the information that David Cunningham
has been put into the application is
from a from an officer point of view
going into that it's an officer input
which we normally accept at any point
and it wouldn't be something that we
would then seek
comment on this so like any comment we
got in from any consulting or any
comment made by any officer previously
as members were aware in the council May
well recall this the council didn't have
its own qualified arboriculturalist
which is why we then sought the advice
of Mr booth at that time David
Cunningham recently appointed our
Borough cultural officer is a qualified
Arbor and
as you would expect we place great
weight on on his advice as we would with
our heritage officer or with our own
policy officers so the methodology is
not consistent absolutely I think David
would
happily accept that but he's taken a
view that the methodologies Graham's
outlined and measuring the appropriate
RPA of the trees should be from the
individual trees and as you've seen from
Graham's device that is actually greater
an extent than Mr Booth's methodology
where he took screen said a clump of
trees and established his RPA from that
so so again as as we discussed with the
the application previously officers have
taken the view that there is the extant
for that position
but that the opportunity is there now
for an extended RPA to properly protect
all the trees which Graham and David
have been out and individually measured
with Mr Mrs Harry's and therefore from
the advice we're getting from David a
qualified arboriculturist he is of the
view that with the RPA on the line of
the well with the dotted dash line that
Graham's talked about that is going to
properly protect the trees is actually
better than what could be fell back to
so if you if you again the argument is
the same as the last application if you
were to Grant permission this afternoon
the applicant has two options but he
can't Implement both he has to implement
one or the other
and as with the application at hallfield
gate lane an office of view is that
there is benefit from getting a greater
RPA in this case
rather than the smaller RPA that could
otherwise be used
I hope that explains it to councilor
Cooper Chen hopefully in a way that you
can understand the reasoning that we
have had his officers in coming to our
conclusion on this application
councilor Cooper
um thank you for that chair and thanks
for that Adrian um
plot six
um basically a books
that RPA
is that acceptable
it's literally on the line
I guess that's splitting ears but it's
it's it really is on the line
um can you just uh help me out with that
one please
yeah
it must be me yeah
so hopefully you can see from the the
plant although you might be able to see
it from uh councilor Cooper we can get
it on me
but yeah you're right the garage for
clot six is right on that line
but I think what the advice is that
David David was telling me is that that
is the root protection area it won't go
into that area
and I think that David was advising that
that is it is it is a guide
to create the kind of Maximum kind of
protection for those trees you know the
garage won't go into that RPA and I
think we're taking the view that that is
that is acceptable
you know we'd make we are taking as
officers or the measures above and
beyond what we've previously
approved by removing preventative
development rights for those properties
all on that boundary so to prevent
outstanding extensions and our buildings
and we think that that will give a
greater greater protection
foreign
for debate
we all understand how to put emotion in
if there's no debate
no I've got motion on the table is to go
with officers recommendations
okay
would go with a vote
right councilor Armitage
councilor Cooper
councilor Elliot
councilor Foster for
councilor Hancock for
councilor Hartson for
councilor Liggins abstain
Angela Jones
oh excuse me
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse
four
and counselor Roth oh
the motion has passed you thank you
um item six is just gained the same site
um is there anything any different the
speakers wish to say on that
yep if you'd like to start thank you
I'm allowing the same five minutes okay
thank you
sure just um before you move it and
there is a slightly different
presentation ahead of times if you want
the offices to go through that first of
all
just
okay so thanks Adrian uh
so this is the second of the
applications at high stairs Lane this is
a section 73 application it's a very
condition one the approved plans
of Plenty approval 17768 RM to vary the
scale and appearance details
so the main issues here being whether or
not the changes to the scale and
appearance details are acceptable on the
site the surrounding area resonance
privacy and amenity and again on the
trees to the west of the site
next slide
okay thank you so this is the same slide
as before illustrating the extent of the
site in Orange and shows the
relationship with the surrounding area
so this and the next couple of slides
have been submitted by the developer and
offer an illustrative view of how the
development may appear once constructed
okay so this is and I'll show you a few
a selection of the house types compared
to those previously granted so this
house type is the Durham to be used on
plots four and five materials to be used
on this and the scheme in general are
red brick to complement the surrounding
Street Scene
so the next slide this is the previously
approved house type plots four and five
next slide please
so this house type is the Barnard and
will be constructed on plots 22-24
this would be a prominent house type as
a Terrace ranging from the a61
and in Harris excuse me in comparison to
the previously approved scheme Mouse
type in those plots this next slide
please
so this outside the Waterford and this
is used at the site entrance on block 25
and then in comparison
this is the previously approved house
type in that location
and finally
so this is the bambra and it'll be
constructed on plot 7 close to the
boundary with Prospect house
you'll note the two Upper Floor windows
on the inside elevation in that top
right hand corner they'll face towards
Prospect house but these can be
commissioned to the obscurely glazed and
have only high level opening
and in on comparison again to the
previously approved house type
this is the one plot seven and this only
had one window in the Upper Floor and
that was proposed to be
thank you thank you for your patience
off you go
thank you so the planet officers report
advised to the committee that the
proposal was broadly the same
um that was previously approved and that
there were subtle changes to the scale
and appearance of the dwellings I'm
afraid our analysis of the data well the
data that's available or decipherable
shows that there is a significant impact
on the scale and appearance and that is
why this application should be rejected
today so let's get into some specifics
nine out of the 28 properties on the
site have an increase in the number of
bedrooms that's 32 of the properties on
the site the total number of bedrooms
increases from 94 to 103. this is a 10
increase in size the previous scheme had
no five bedroom properties
to accommodate this these homes are
significantly larger in their structure
this also highlights impacts on the use
of the development larger homes with
more residents leads to impact on
considerations and traffic movements
parking facilities and by just glossing
over the details the impact of these
changes none of this has been properly
considered a simple comparison on the
increase in bedrooms shows the increase
in scale as the bedrooms need extra
space the houses are significantly
bigger plot 7 as an example as an
increased width of 27 and an increase in
20 of its total footprint the
significant change impacts the overall
Aesthetics of the development with an
increase of 15 larger first floor spaces
and all of the figures that I've used
here we've shared um the details via
email with all committee members
um all of our workings and things so I'm
not sure where other figures have come
from but these are our findings with the
information that's been made available
to us
the building Footprints in total covered
70 square meters more than the
previously approved scheme six of the 28
properties in the proposed application
now have three-story Living Spaces
previously there were no three-story
properties
the bigger houses they need more windows
to take a specific example the Wild
Goose Design at plot one was hornbeam so
this lies on high stairs Lane the
property had 13 windows the proposed
Meadowview home of bumbra has 16 Windows
the Bamber property has an increase in
the number of first floor windows in the
side elevation which overlooks
properties green end and more fields on
high stairs Lane do residents of
Stratton not deserve to be protected
from this invasion of their privacy why
has this not been considered why is no
mitigation even been considered to this
change
the significantly larger properties as
already described a result in large
Banks of properties allowing for Less
light on site and to the neighboring
properties you could see that on the
drawings that have already been shared
the previous housing types allowed for
undulating roof lines from the garages
and allowed for a more open aspect of
the development
as a specific example of these changes
in relation to plots 15 16 and 17 along
the a61 the planning officer refers to
the removal of some garages but all this
has done is to allow bigger wider fronts
of properties at these three plots and
it'll create a wall of properties with
little light able to pass through these
properties already Tower over those
already along the a61 and this will
impact them even more but again I don't
see that this has been considered
I recall the previous applications where
we were provided with numerous different
representations of what the development
would look like from different angles
from different viewpoints around the
site and considering that we're looking
at our parents today I've not seen any
evidence of this so I suppose we're just
supposed to use our imaginations
so it's very easy to gloss over these
changes and determine each one of them
as minor but the committee needs to
consider the collective impact of the
changes why should a developer be
allowed to flaunt the planning process
by implementing a drastic change in a
scheme with numerous impacts and then it
only be deemed to be broadly the same
the application should be rejected due
to the significant impacts of the scale
and appearance of this development
thank you
thank you are there any questions from
the speaker
councilor yeah
thank you
um you're saying about the property on
high stairs laying with 13 Windows now
with 16. will that impact Prospect hours
so the nearest wave if I think Riley and
I stairs Lane the next property is a
bungalow going towards the garage
yes on the other side of the road
probably some 50 meters away again so
this where the property that I'm talking
about will lie is if you turn up the a60
up from the n61 towards prospect's house
there's a hedge that runs along the left
hand side about where the opening of
that driveway is will be the front of
that house the side elevation which then
looks towards the um driveway the
Gateway of um prospect's house is here
and then you have green end and more
Fields so those windows will look into
those problems do you know how far it is
from each elevation to Elevation roughly
40 meters 50 meters
across the width of the lane yeah
so 30 30 odd meters mostly
thank you
any other questions
no thank you you'd like to take a seat
Mr Milhouse
again you're reported to five minutes
thanks again
um I'll keep this brief and limits it to
um scale and appearance so I'm not
repeating myself
um so the main the main point I want to
make is is again the the suggestion that
the size and scale has increased
significantly is is is categorically not
the case
um it is true that six of the houses
have an additional floor of
accommodation
but these are Loft conversions in effect
um so what you would ordinarily be able
to do on a permitted development all 28
of the houses will will appear as
two-story properties not three-story
properties from the street
um and an important fact the the rich
height of every single one of the 28
properties is actually lower than was
what what was previously approved
um so none of them none of them got any
higher all of them have got a bit lower
um
so so yeah there's no there's no
meaningful increase in scale
um
block seven as I said in my last uh
Speech has got one and a half meters
longer that that's all uh but it's also
got narrower and lower
um and the windows in plot seven on the
rear on the previously approved scheme
there was a um a bathroom window to be
obscure glaze now there'll be two
bathroom Windows to be obscure glaze but
those windows are smaller than one
previously approved so you know in
totality there's very little meaningful
difference
um with regards the appearance of the
properties
um
we tried to stay close to the
um previously approved scheme while
still obviously incorporating Meadowview
homes own house types
um so there's a lot of traditional
detailing in there
um we've got red brick with uh with
um ventilated Coral detail
um a mixture of brick Sills and arched
headers and some Stone lintels and Sills
we've got canopy porches bay windows all
of these features appeared in the
original approved scheme or will reflect
the local binocular uh We've submitted
some visuals that have been on the
screen just now we've submitted also
photographs of the Westington
development which is quite similar it's
been built by Meadowview in my view high
quality design
um that is acceptable in planning terms
thank you
thank you any questions
I don't blame you for not wanting
questions
and the three three bed properties that
you say appear as a normal two-story
dwelling are they situated along the
main road or are they situated on the
edge down eye stairs or either within
the plot uh within within the plot and
it it's six actually to to be to be fair
six of the properties will will have in
effect rooms in the roof
um they're inside of the site as it were
so further back into the site I I would
agree that on you know in principle they
do look very similar and uh to to get
the lesson Ridge highs Etc is that the
actual measurement of the build or if
you dug into the topography now it's a
measure of the build I I you know we
scaled off the drawings of the old
scheme in the new scheme
um so that's generally
um
achieved by making the gables narrower
so you narrow the Gable and the woods
tends to drop
okay thank you okay thank you councilor
look at I'm going again sorry um
I just wondered if the extra bedrooms at
um meant that you'd have to change the
extra car park in our extra hard sanding
from the original
um
no
um
we we don't
believe there's any any need to
um the highway Authority hadn't
recommended that that's necessary that
there's plenty of off-street parking
being provided
um through driveways garages and such
like
um so
so yeah we we don't feel that that's
that's necessary and and like I said the
highway offices
um haven't advised us that it's
necessary either so
make your Escape quick
are there any further questions no thank
you Now's the Time to retreat
Texas
as there's no more questions I'll open
the floor for debate if councilor
Hancock chair it's just a request if you
don't mind would um Graeme just mind
doing the comparisons between the two
designs again just bringing them up so
that we can have a question
do you mean the site plan David or the
houses
okay
so this is the the three one the
two-story property that is proposed
which has got accommodation over three
levels so this is the Durham
so this is plots
yeah plus four five uh 27 28 and 20 and
21 within the scheme so six units
and compared to the previously approved
house type
that's what that looked like it's gonna
just flip between
it's a very similar in appearance you
know on the on the proposed scheme
leaves are slightly lower I think that
helps just bring that right down a
little bit so if we move on to the next
house type would you want me to go
through all of these
so this is the the row of Terror so plot
22 24 sits on the corner of high stairs
so it's very very prominent in the
scheme so this is what's proposed
compared to
what was previously approved on the next
slide
so it could be argued that you know the
proposed house type is actually
got a little bit more character to it
and then the next house type
so this is this is I think this is one
at the site entrance plot 25 so this
will front right onto
the entrance another side on to high
stairs Lane and in comparison to the
previously approved house type
you know it's
not vastly different
so if we move to the next house type
so this one's
and this is plot seven so this is the
one that has quite a close interaction
with the boundary
West so in comparison to the previous
approved Mouse type
so
yes it is
I think we might get well widths and
lengths a bit of cross-reference here is
is a little bit longer
so as you view from prospect's house it
is a little bit wider
I think I've worked out that you know
the massing on that boundary is probably
only about 10 difference
hopefully that helps councilor Hancock
is that okay okay
any other questions
any other opening for debate
no I'll move it for a motion then
no I'll put a motion on the table then
that we go for officer's recommendations
thank you
second Mountain thank you
both weekends all right thank you chair
councilor Armitage
councilor Cooper
counselor Elliot
councilor Foster or
councilor Hancock against
anselor Hartzell or
abstain
councilor Jones
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse for
councilor Roth for
so I make it uh five for the motion re
against and three abstained
the motion is pasture thank you okay
thank you all very much
Google Chat
a slight uh issue but if you want a
quick five minute break please take it
now I am counting
properties to the south on homesdale
close are set at a lower level to the
application site so next slide please
this is a block plan of the site
illustrating the site in comparison to
the surrounding Street Scene the hatched
area on the plan in the northwest corner
which hopefully you can just make out
that is the extent of the two-story
extension which is kind of infilling a
little area so you've got that and
you're also changing the hip to a pitch
roof
you can see the properties on Bounce
Crescent are a mix of detached Bungalows
and semi-detached two-story dwellings
next slide please
so this drawing compares the existing
and the proposed front and rear
elevations as you can see the hip is
removed and replaced with a pitch roof
with box Dormers
the rear elevation includes Juliet
balcony and this will be in excess of 21
meters as set out in the successful
places guidance and as Adrian's just
confirmed
is approximately 28 meters
rear to rear okay
next slide please
so the next two slides compare side
elevations as you can see the hip is
taken from the roof
and we're increasing the eaves and the
ridge by 0.7 of a meter
and box Dormers are included in the side
elevations
the Upper Floor windows will be
obscurely glazed and will only have high
level openings and this can be
controlled by wave condition
next slide
so this is the other side elevation
again the window shown can be obscurely
glazed and conditioned to be high level
opening only
next slide please
so this shows the proposed first floor
plan illustrating the living bathroom
and bedroom accommodation to be provided
the flat roof Illustrated on this plan
just to the bottom of that drawing
that will not be used as a balcony and
this has been confirmed by the applicant
and a suitably worded condition is
included in the recommendation just to
cover this matter
it's like this
so this photo shows the application site
on the right hand side and number 22 on
the left there
the next slide
so this photo shows the application site
there on the left and number 18 on the
right
the next slide please so this is you
know hopefully taken from number 18
bence Crescent on my site visit
and it's looking back towards the
application site so just for clarity the
proposed first floor extension will not
extend above that single story element
that you can see that flat roof part
next slide please
this is just an example of some of the
properties opposite on bent's Crescent
as you can see it's quite a mix you've
got bungalows in the background and
these semi-detached two-story properties
and the final slide please
this is just a view taken from the
application site looking South you just
see the roofs of properties on homesdale
close just in the background there
beyond that hedge and that concludes the
presentation
thank you
I believe we have three speakers for
this application and the first speaker
is a Mr Michael carp you'd like to take
the seat please
you have three minutes when you're ready
Mr Carr
okay she was just press the microphone
thanks
thank you
may I start
thank you
there is a very good reason why the nine
core objectives living directly adjacent
to a ball drink 20 minutes Crescent are
still totally against this application
even after nearly two years have failed
attendance by the applicants
we vehemently believed that the proposed
new build contravenes the adopted local
Plumb policy H5 and the emerging plan
policy lc5
excuse me we'll state that domestic
extension should be in keeping with the
existing property and the street scene
in terms of their style proportion and
materials and should avoid significant
loss of privacy and amenity for
neighboring residents
my objections today revolve around that
loss of privacy and immunity
this has not been satisfactorily
resolved in the new proposals will
result in a significantly more prominent
dwelling
which clearly will be scenically
overbearing or into its questionable
design faults
the plan
will also allow the obstruction of the
fabulous view over the Drone Augusta
Valley
all those who enjoyed the rotary 2000
walks and rumbles will be denied this to
you as they leave the Green Lane section
of the Woodland Trail we changed it
exits opposite the Bungalow
this tools is indefensible
because of this the development is
contrary to policy D3 at the drumfield
neighborhood plan and the overarching
games that the national planning policy
framework
acceptance to this planning application
is anomalous because a steep Hillside
location of all the effective properties
the angler to have declination itself is
exaggerated such a radical
and I've lost my place just hang on uh
just to subscribe
extent that visual intrusion and loss of
existing lights and immediately is
inevitable
it will cause lots of social privacy for
bungalows numbers five seven nine and
eleven Holmesdale close and sudden
Gardens will be subjected to unwarranted
visual intrusion
there isn't a hedge tall enough to
resolve those problems
the residents believe that the committee
should view the lay of the land around
20 pence Crescent they will then
appreciate our concerns 30 seconds
remain
thank you
this is essential as you are all aware
ours is a very conservative Community
which has a democratic a demographic of
more than 80 percent retirees
we are an oasis in the center of the
Vital Center of drumfield family life
we have already suffered two years of
Anguish now it's a good time for the
planning department to make a stand a
similarly dismiss this application is
that it do you want me to stop yes
please okay thank you very much
if you just remain in your C are there
any questions
no if you'd like to take your seat
behind thank you thank you very much
said our next speaker is Christina
Rogers
three minutes when you're ready
the objection I'm putting forward today
is in relation to item 7.5 on page 72 of
your agenda which states the surrounding
street is a mix of Bungalows and
semi-detached properties this makes it
appear there is a similar number of each
type of property and the fact is there
are just three pairs of semis on the
Crescent amongst which all in one pair
is on the same side as the proposed
extension and that's some five Bungalows
away from the proposed extension
it's not like there's a bungalow then a
semi then a bungalow then a semi uh the
semi's shown in the photograph are
actually on the opposite side of the
road
um this project is in effect put in a
two-story style building in amongst a
row of bungalows
now you might say that the neighboring
property at number 22 I think you've
seen it with the dormant style stop top
as a box Dormer perched above the ridge
line but from the photos on
that you're seeing you will notice that
they've maintained their hit roof
still giving the frontage a bungalow
Style
the frontage on the proposed development
will have the appearance of a true story
dwelling in amongst Bungalows giving the
street scene a very higgledy-piggledy
appearance
also permission for the original
application of a second of a second
story extension was turned down and I
quote it would appear overly prominent
and appear as an incongruous Edition out
of character with the sound the
surrounding Street Scene
I would respect respectfully suggest
with regards to the impacts of the
street scene of this amended application
nothing has changed so I'm not sure how
the council's officer could consider
that this proposed extension would be of
an acceptable style
proportion and materials which would
complement the mixed surrounding street
scene on behalf of the neighborhood I
request that the application for this
project be rejected
thank you thank you any questions sorry
nervous counselor Elliot thank you uh
what number do you live at please
18. thank you
any questions for the officers councilor
Foster
thank you chair uh my question sorry
I've missed one out I've kicked him up
my list already I've got one more
speaker
of the applicants okay
good afternoon
three minutes when you're ready yeah
okay so uh yeah uh the reason we've uh
applied for planning permission for the
property is basically uh to extend the
property due to the fact that
potentially we may have to look after
our uh my father-in-law
uh as is an ill health
uh We've this has just been going on for
two years now we've changed from the
original plans where I have complied as
a resident
every planning recommendation by the
Northeast Derbyshire planners
so from day one I've done everything
we've changed the the
uh the aspect of the rear we've changed
the aspect of the height of the roof
it's not going to be any higher so it
won't impact on any views at all uh
uh we've changed Kevin figg the previous
planning officer agreed that we could
have windows down the side uh
our neighbors are 18 said on in October
that if we took those two windows out
and the two windows on the other side
that it wouldn't go to planning
they've obviously
changed the mind about that but I have
done everything in my power
to make sure that I've gone with any
local planning laws
uh and that's all I'm going to say about
it thank you are there any questions
you can't speak any further if you'd
like to take a seat thank you
right back to the office's question
sorry counselor
uh thank you chair a question for
officers it's about uh when you look at
the elevation picture either the front
or the rear elevation if you bring you
to help one thing that's not that clear
uh and I've visited uh this side and
I've realized when I stood there exactly
how overbearing I thought this would be
so my question is if the officers can
bring up the uh the real front elevation
the the Bungalows are quite close
together the drives are uh narrow uh
narrow enough for an old-fashioned car
as a as they would once fit
and when when you stand on the drive you
can see how the Ridge High which is 0.7
meters higher would have an effect you
could see that and it has an effect of
1.7 meters does but then if you look at
that box Dormer the actual not that but
the elevation the plans
yeah and what's not so clear which I'd
like Clarity on if you were to stand uh
where it says proposed to the left of
that and you look up with your eye level
if that goes on the uh the 0.7 of a
meter you can obviously if you could see
the ridge you could see would have an an
effect and it looks overbearing if you
look at where the actual box Dormer
comes out and where the edge of that new
gutter would be if there would be a
gutter there as the as the overall
effect and that's what I wanted some
clarity on there you could see where it
would be where your eye line would be
and it shows how much how overbearing
the actual box Dome would be uh and
that's one of the reasons I asked this
one of the reasons why I asked this to
come to this Committee in the first
place it has such a no an effect there
and you can't tell from the drawings
unless you look at the front television
and draw a line across that box Dormer
the edge of that box Dormer and you
could see actually how overbearing it is
an ample light would actually block out
so I wonder if you could provide some
clarity on that just uh
the officer could
and the other one was a question around
the uh the overlooking of those deal
Clause so that first one please
just in terms of the first point I'll
and I think this is the issue that um as
The Fosters mentioning is is that if you
look from there I think this is right it
kind of supposed to do I'm not right but
with the eaves being raised by the 0.7
with the gay will be informed you're
then saying that the Box Dormer that
would be viewed on both side elevations
will when you look at it and be out so
you couldn't see the Apex
so and that's a that's a consideration
that you will need to take into account
but from from an officer point of view
we will look at it in terms of um the
impact on the amenity of the Neighbors
in in terms of the amenity issue so set
aside what it looks like just for a
second because you're meeting as well in
terms of the impact on the neighbors we
would say that because the the rear face
of the extension is in line with the
properties either side
the the impact on the amenity of those
properties particularly those at bence
Crescent because they their Outlook is
towards the South wouldn't in our
opinion be
overly overridingly detrimental so I'm
not saying it doesn't have an impact but
then you have to assess if that impact
is harmful
and in terms of the
um bulk of that box Dormer yes it will
have an impact on the neighbor there's
no doubt about that whether it's harmful
and our viewers offices is that it
wouldn't be overridely harmful we would
always place
less emphasis on the protection of side
windows to properties because they can
be and they can put a two meter high
fence next door to your neighbor Etc so
we will put more weight on the
protection of that amenity than we would
on rear facing or front-facing Windows
where you would normally expect some
Outlook
so I'm I'm hoping that gives a flavor of
why we've arrived at our viewers offices
but yes you will need to take that issue
into account I appreciate that actually
I've got one second question uh that was
more about how it would look from from
the drive of the neighbors here you see
you can quite step back into into 18 but
if you move further near the car you
wouldn't see that Ridge at all that
rigid completely disappear and all you
would see is uh is you know it'd be
blocked off completely so it's that
overbearing uh
uh and the the next question was around
uh 28 meters which she did provide some
give some clarity on
um at the beginning of this uh this
presentation the 28 meters is from the
actual Juliet Balcony itself uh to the x
uh to the rear of the properties at
Holmesdale close that's 28 meters but
there are some properties there with
extensions so uh if we look at it uh
what would be the distance to the river
those extensions roughly
I can't be to the millimeter but
um from the Juliet Balcony to the rear
most
um extension I'm taking number nine so
just on the the drawing there you can
see number nine on Holmesdale closed its
rear extension isn't shown so there is a
rear extension to homesdale close and
roughly the
the distance from the Juliet Balcony to
the rear most point of that would be
approximately 24 meters that's not right
26 meters because we've taken two meters
off the application property because
they've got their single story rear
extension and two meters off the
extension at homesdale close
and um we just weighed that in terms of
these successful places 21 meters you
would normally look for but then of
course in this instance you also got to
take into account the top again
topographical difference to the
difference in the levels between the
application property and homesdale close
uh yeah I wasn't I wasn't going to come
on to that until the actual debate
um how it does how it does look when you
stood then it just you can see straight
down it faces uh it goes straight in the
rear bedroom windows absolutely but I
also want to come on come on slightly in
the debate
photograph chair was and Graham's sought
to demonstrate that although that
photograph is taken from ground level at
the application property
so um let's not take it from where the
Julian balcony would be like that would
be the higher
just just to be fair
before you take the pictures away Adrian
can you go back to one where it shows
you the did I say hideous extension
that's next door
so how does that affect
the Privacy issue of um looking down
onto the other Bungalows are there
windows at the back of that extension
do we know
in the Box in that box Dormer yeah I
believe I believe there are windows
facing forwards onto Ben's Crescent
there's a Sidewinder that you can see
there's also a window
facing towards homesdale close as well
so with the proposed extension for the
applicant is it the same height as that
box
or less
I think that's difficult for me to
answer because I've not got the plans
for that in front of me it
it could be very similar it might be
slightly above it
it's it's hard for me to kind of kind of
and the proposed extension will be
slightly further back
in the roof slope won't it but
I think what we're trying to be clear is
that
the first floor extension won't go any
further than where you can see the
downpipe
and say
I think what we've taken a view on as
offices is that significantly harmful in
privacy in the military in privacy
Community times
the requirement is 21 meters and we
appreciate the topographical changes
but there's also the guidance in
successful places requires 10 and a half
meters from the Upper Floor window to
the rear boundary
and this comfortably meets that I
believe it's probably about 12 meters so
yes there will be overlooking but is
that significantly harmful I think
that's what we have to weigh up here
any other questions for the council
Cooper
um it may not
may not be a question but I would have
to say that from a design point of view
this application looks far more
appealing than the one two doors away
I think we can all agree with that
one it's actually right next door isn't
it
yeah okay
okay are there any further questions
from the officers
no okay Floors open for debate
there is none
oh councilor Foster
uh yep uh there's been considerable
interest in this we've got uh three
people which have come to speak but I've
had no end of uh people uh calling and
emailing me we've got 20 objections that
are uh that come through here
uh but Avid more than that uh as the as
the ward member uh it's difficult to see
uh from these pictures because it gives
you the appearance and I think we've
heard from one of the residents there
are only three sets of semis on that
road it's largely uh a road a crescent
uh solely of Bungalows and
four sets of semis not three sets uh I
stand corrected uh we shouldn't be
judging this on that previous
monstrosity further up the road
and as the gentleman said he's got no
privacy that's no reason for for us to
pass something like this and give other
residents no privacy especially the
people on Holmesdale Road when you look
about how over overbearing it is it
really is it looks right down on all
those the river those at least five
property properties uh and that's when
we take into account the topographical
side of things thank you for that
uh what's clear here is uh this was
previously applied for and it was turned
down by officers in 2021. it was a very
very similar
uh Second Story in that case uh
application this is something different
and I can see that the gentleman the
applicants wanted to work with our
offices but in practice and effect it's
much the same thing on residents
it does two things one for the residents
either side it's uh it's overbearing
which of trying to explain when you look
at that uh the age of the uh the uh the
new box Dormer
and the other one it overlooks those
properties on Holmesdale close and you
can see although it's not there it's
more than the 21 meters which is
required in the good design guide it's
very very close when you look at uh
we've said in uh
26 meters so it's very very close to
that so it does two things uh so for
myself it's something we shouldn't be uh
we shouldn't be agreeing to here so when
it comes down to motions uh for me what
it contravenes is D3
and when we look at D3 in the in the
dronfield neighborhood plan uh it's
mentioned in 7.3 at page 72. it's
mentioned one specific part of D3 but
it's not that far which concerns me it's
another part of D3
and uh the officers will have this it
says should not adversely impact on
General amenity and give careful
consideration so now use over the light
and loss of light to exist in properties
so that goes that actually if you look
at that part of D3 it goes against
policy there and that's loss of light to
existing properties
um in in good design D3 John Field and
that's not being quoted by officers and
actually have that uh that part answered
and when it comes to our local plan it's
certainly contravenous policy lc5 uh
residence residential extensions and
that as we've had stated already 7.2 lc5
requires that domestic extension should
be in keeping with the existing property
should be in keeping and Street Scene
certainly not when it comes to street
scene in terms of their style
proportional materials and should avoid
significant loss of privacy this does uh
give lots of privacy and it is
significant in my view an immunity for
neighboring residents so it goes against
two policies there uh lc5 uh local plan
and D3 of the dronfield neighborhood
plant and it's a shame not to have D3
mentioned in uh in this report
thank you chair
any other comment
helps to Hancock
thank you chair I've got to admit I'm a
little bit torn on this one because
I'm not sold on the street scene
argument because that street has got a
lot of variety and as you rightly said
the one next door is so housekeeping
with everything else it's it's difficult
to then say well nothing else is going
to be within in the street scene but
I do have concerns as to the extent of
overlooking and I'm torn as to whether
there's um whether it is significant
overlooking on the neighboring
Properties or whether it would be
acceptable given the distance
um I mean Mark knows the area much
better than I do and I know uh I mean
obviously you're raising concerns in in
terms of that
um on the side that faces um this couple
the windows have gone haven't they from
from the thing there's no window are
they on on that side right right yeah
yeah so I'm still a little bit torn but
um it's the Privacy aspect that concerns
me if I'm truthful
any no you can't anymore sorry
um
any further comments
um just just briefly share just on a
couple of points that have been raised
just in terms of the the discussion
about impact on on amenity is the the
two issues and it has to Fosters talked
about the yoga bearings and that that's
an issue you'll need to assess and
consider just in terms of the impact on
amenity to the windows per se from from
looking into Windows members will note
that these side windows would all be
obscurely glazed so there would be no
um direct looking into enabling windows
so hopefully that helps on on that side
of things and because the Foster has
mentioned the issue about the book and
you'll need to assess that and our
viewers offices is that that in an
overriding assessment that that's your
planning consideration and judgment you
need to make just in terms of the
impact on the neighbors to the rear
again just to um come back to that the
the minimum distance is set out in
successful places is met and you need to
assess them whether the difference in
the levels or any other issue means that
because that distance is met and
exceeded that there is still harm so
that's the the Judgment again that
you'll need to have to to take on those
issues hope that helps thank you
thank you any other considerations
councilor Foster yeah just come back on
uh on
um at Mr kirkham's uh comments there at
that distance is met but due to the
elevation and how it looks into the
river those properties uh that distance
is not enough and you can see that when
you're there quite clearly
um
thank you
thank you well we're at the point now is
that someone wanted to put a motion on
the table councilor Foster I'm happy to
propose that we go against officers
recommendations and turn down this this
application uh based on D3 uh the
neighborhood plan which is very very
clear uh when you read it's a shame we
don't have that in front of us and that
happily have a officers come back on
that
um
so it should not adversely impact on
General Amino to end your careful
consideration to noise or the light and
loss of light to existing properties so
that part of D3
and lc5 residential extensions uh as
I've already stated so I'd like to
propose that chair
thank you do I have a second
councilor diggett chair in fact just be
um some clarity from first of all on the
issue of D3 and as The Fosters right
that the issue of D3 is an issue for
amenities well we've we've majored on
the issue of Street Scene at paragraph
7.3 but I take the point of cancer
Foster makes on that chair and just in
terms of the reason for refusal just to
be to to be clear again is the issue
that members that the the cast of foster
is concerned about is the issue on
amenity and we're not talking about the
issue of design or is it both
I'm not trying to to take you down one
route I just want to be clear so that I
appreciate that it's uh it's about the
matter and it's about the overbearance
it's about loss of privacy and uh and
also the street scene I'll come back on
uh councilor Hancock's uh comment
there's a lot of variety it's not the
case when you go on the street that the
we've had the pictures you've seen are
of those semis and then several times
we've seen a picture of that awful box
Dormer further up this the the photos
are focused on that the rest of the
streets is a is is uh you know the
lovely Bungalows all of them so so it's
a shame that we've seen those photos
because there's not a lot of variety on
that road at all thank you chair
so just to I've just noted down here um
overbearance loss of amenity loss of
light and impact on street scene
thank you
and in fact yeah it's coming back on
that it's much the same reasons as the
last one was turned down they didn't
come to come into the offices turned
down when they went for on the
applicants went for a second uh for a
first floor
okay are we ready all right okay sure so
the motion is to refuse officer
recommended I um produced the
application against officer
recommendations for the reasons and I've
just specified
um councilor Armitage
counselor Cooper
councilor Elliot
councilor Foster or
councilor Hancock against
councilor Liggett for
counselor Jones Gaines
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse against
and councilor Roth against
so that's five for the motion and six
against the motion has fallen sure
thank you I'll put motion on the table
that we go for office's recommendations
we need a second
thank you
nature uh councilor Armitage
councilor Cooper
and alias
councilor Foster against
councilor Hancock for
counselor Hartzell or
councilor ligate against
councilor Jones
councilor Powell
counselor Rouse for
and councilor ruff
so it's seven for the motion and four
against the motionless pasture
thank you right that's the main section
of that business
late representations we've done planning
Appeals
you just um see chair that there were
two appeals lodged during the last um
four weeks um any further decisions we
we get will report in due course but
there's no reported decisions in the
past four weeks chair
thank you are there any questions
no thank you
I don't have any matters of urgency but
what has been brought to my attention is
that we all know Julie Hill that was
part of our group before she became ill
she's part of the singing group for
dementia and they've it's a CD they've
released it
this is a CD that Julie is now on yes
yes
so if you'd like to dig deep it's going
to a worthy cause the dementia and I'm
not sure where you can purchase it
online thank you so please look out for
it and it just for me to say I wish you
all a Merry Christmas and a Happy New
Year and I'll see you back in January
thank you